Yeah yeah yeah
Kokoro-san it's
dangerous Nakae I don't care
She says she wants to be here But I won't touch
her She's
not a site if I protect it I have nothing
anymore No one can do it
20  Java server 2.2 is the attitude,
so let me be here Then I'll support you here too There's
no need to feel responsible, it's not a responsibility
anymore Please don't say there's nothing
Stand up
, there's nothing even a country
I've already found my reason to live I want to protect
the future of that child called you I'm weak
The feeling of loving you is still stupid I
thought I could walk with you
[music]
[Music]
Even if you don't remember anything, you can start from scratch I
'll call you
whatever you want That's our battle
[Music]
me
ana
I'm
sorry Heart